hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar standardizing microbiome X
removing bias complexion
education and analyses and Judy O'Rourke
lab roots and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminars
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by saima
research design will research
corporation based in Irvine California
has been providing the scientific
community with comprehensive nucleic
acid solutions for DNA and RNA research
and epigenetics more than two decades
the company's unique achievements
include development of the first
available microdilution in column
technology or nucleic acid purification
into thousands i mo was among the first
companies to offer products for
epigenetics based research in 2011 the
company launched its genetic and
epigenetic services with
state-of-the-art next-gen sequencing and
bioinformatics technology to date
designo maintains the most comprehensive
offering of services or genetic
epigenetic and transcriptome analysis to
learn more visit www GMO research com
let's get started this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or hearing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button lower left I now
present today's speakers Ryan Kemp MS
and sweet and hong PhD lion temp is the
director of nucleic acid solutions for
syma research chem joins I'm o in 2012
as a research scientist and has since
led the development of multiple novel
DNA and RNA purification technologies
his background is in organic chemistry
where he developed artificial receptors
for an eye on recognition in his current
role he has been instrumental and
development of many of xiamen researches
innovative products including zainal
plasmid DNA kit DNA RNA shield and
technologies inside many of the quick
DNA kits camp also contributed a text
after and sample preparation techniques
for soil plant and animal samples
published by Springer in 2016 discussing
techniques for nucleic acids nucleic
acid isolation dr. sweet Jen pong is a
research scientist at bio research he
received a PhD in the department of
chemical engineering and applied
chemistry from the university of toronto
dr. Tom Verlaine's Naimah research in
2014 and has since been instrumental in
the research and development of xylose
microbiome Ock's and metagenomics
program this past experiences include
working the fields of environmental
microbiology and biological process
engineering with an emphasis on
bioinformatics metagenomics and
anaerobic cultivation most recently dr.
Tong has been involved in the
development of agile researches
microbial mix portfolio he has multiple
publications in different journals
including frontiers in microbiology
applied and environmental microbiology
and philosophical transactions of the
royal society of london series b
biological science running camp will now
begin presentation good morning everyone
thank you for attending some researchers
webinar and microbio mix today we'll be
discussing how we are efforts basically
to remove bias and collection
purification and analyses so with the
massive boom in microbio mixes over the
past several years you can see almost
20,000 citations in 2015 alone and also
major growth in just a number of ross
searches and epigenetics verse
epigenetics based on Google Trends
almost matching it now in 2016 however
despite the a major growth there's been
a lag in the development of standards
and standardized methods for enabling
reproducibility across studies and in a
study a couple years ago presented by
science news the author submitted
samples to two major commercial
organizations American gut and you buy
them and you'll notice that their
samples submitted to American gut they
found that the Firmicutes were about
thirty percent well you biome they
observe something like seventy percent
so with the sample they're seeing such
huge differences but there's no there's
no standards to actually determine which
one is actually true so even from these
major commercial organizations there's
there's no reproducibility and this is a
become a major concern in the microbiome
until thus far so therefore there's been
a real call for standard standardizing
microbiol mixed in the short term and
FDA has been calling for it NIST and I
of the national institute of standards
and technologies been working at they
had a workshop in the last fall they
have another workshop coming in this
fall on the standards for microbiome
research the MV QC project which is the
microbiome quality control project led
by many of the people who are also
leading the human microbiome project are
also calling for standardization and the
requirement for stan is to create
standard methods the ABR MGR g group has
also been developing standards and
working on standardized methods as well
so as you can see many many groups are
actually calling for this so you can
begin these longitudinal studies and
have reproducible work between groups
in an assessment of a u.s. microbiome
research article those recently
published one of the major calls were
was for standardized protocols and
high-throughput tools were commonly
identified as needs and along with
longitudinal and functional studies and
interdisciplinary research but in order
to have these studies methods must be
reproducible between different labs in
an article baseline study published by
the microbiome quality control project
group the major comments that they had
where microbiome research has grown
exponentially over the past several
years but studies have been difficult to
reproduce across investigations
addressing the sources of variation in
microbiota profiling is critical for
optimizing protocols unfortunately
variation each step in the pipeline is
enormous from physical specimen
collection and processing to
computational quantification of
microbial communities basically what
they're getting at is the entire
workflow which is a pretty long workflow
is prone to significant errors and
biases and that's a little discussable
but here's where some of these errors
can occur so the composition at the time
of collection can be changing due to
microbial growth or decay you can add
nucleic acid degradation and then
actually where and how a samples
collected can also affect or bias the
results or cause erroneous data
downstream so it all starts from the
point of collection during the
extraction process non-uniform lysis of
organisms of differential hardiness can
biased results miss representing certain
organisms or are certain communities as
being biased towards certain easy lights
organisms versus tough lights etc a
library preparation you can have bias or
air due to PCR chimera primers generous
II or bias DNA fragmentation course
sequencing platforms can potentially
have bias and then in the bioinformatics
pipeline itself you can have Aaron
taxonomy assignment or database errors
etc but then in addition to this you
actually have the potential for reagent
and process contamination so depending
on the particular samples you're working
with this can be a much bigger issue
especially at low biomass so as you can
see there's those challenges throughout
the entire pipeline
that everything needs to be dealt with
and you good standards to evaluate this
and that's actually what dymo began a
couple years ago when we first started
really emphasizing and developing a
workflow for microbio mix we realized
that there was not a an abundance of
commercially available standards and
without good standards and controls
there was no way for us to optimize even
our own workflow so that's actually
where we began was developing our own
standards and controls so that we could
then begin to optimize the workflow from
collection all the way through
bioinformatics and that was by Omix is
really just what we quoin our term for
our total solution from question to
analyses so next we'll talk a little bit
about the standard and some
specifications out of construction and
how we characterize it so the novel by
Omix standards we actually have two of
them one will be the microbial standard
which is the cellular standard and then
also we have a DNA standard there's ten
organisms in each they're well
characterized in the predefined
composition meaning we choosing what
goes in and then we characterize it
after the fact to double-check but
basically we know what's going in to
begin with if you look to the left here
we have a genomic abundance of twelve
percent for all the bacteria and two
percent for both the eukaryotes three
gram negative bacteria five gram
positive and two yeast rings this was
chosen very specifically to give us a
range of different organisms so that we
can look at differential hardiness
during the lysis efficiency there's also
a wide range of GC content so that
allows us to look at the problems
potentially library preparation etc due
to biases there from fifteen percent to
five percent another thing that knows we
actually chose specific organisms that
are notoriously difficult to life like
some of the yeast organisms we chose
which are very Hardy but also quite
large and then for instance Listeria
monocytogenes which is quite small and
also quite tough device and Tory ously
difficult so this range allowed us to
create an exemplary model for looking at
a wide range of organisms of course it
doesn't test everything in the world
which is impossible but it creates a
decent model moving forward
this also contains seven pathogens all
of which are inactivated by the DNA RNA
shield which is present so it allows for
safe transport so how we construct this
that everything is coming from course a
single colony then we do the pure
culture cultivation and then we quantify
in the case of microbial standard we
quantify by two methods we actually do
an extraction and look at the DNA and we
also actually do cell counting we use
both of those determine our microbe
pooling then after we actually pull
we've been characterized again using
shotgun metagenomic sequencing and then
for the DNA standard we do have pure
culture cultivation again we extract the
DNA quantify using qubit and then pool
and then characterized after the fact as
well we actually found that our DNA
standard actually has a QC measure for a
microbial standard because once we
validated our workflow in front of the
extraction pipeline and we knew that we
had accurate results we could then use
our postponed characterization as
another measure of validating our
microbial standard which is more
complicated to create this is just
looking at the actual composition and
our by shotgun measure of sequencing and
also 16s and on the lefty seeds of
theoretical on the middle you'll see the
DNA standards and the microbial standard
so this is actually the real extraction
where we extract it using one of our
pits and you can notice you notice that
the profiles are matching very very
close to the theoretical during our
early validations before we have
optimized a kit really for microbio max
we actually were doing a mixture of
things we actually looked at enzymes and
a chemical Isis and be bashing all
together in the early validations of
this to ensure that we had one hundred
percent or close to one hundred percent
lysis of all the organisms and on the
right you'll see the 16s data which also
closely aligns with the theoretical so
then we decided we were going to look at
the impurities within the standard to
ensure that the output what evers people
are seeing what's using our standard is
in
fact and impurity vs vs say errors in
our construction of the standard so we
did 178 million reads using shotgun
sequencing and we use mo to you
profiling the reason why we chose this
was because of very low false positive
rate and this was a method develop I
soon ago at all from in 2013 so if you
notice here are we had one mo to you
count for PF knees which is extremely
low therefore again this just emphasizes
the confidence that you could have that
using these standards that anything
you're seeing besides the organisms that
we State our present are in fact an
error or bias or something in your in
your system your workflow which allows
you to optimize and validate your
workflow using these standards as we
have interesting that it is p acne is
because this actually could have
occurred even during the process itself
because you have the extractions library
prep and as you go through that whole
process any any number one any one of
these places could potentially have you
know a small a small bit of p acne
contamination which is a human skin
organisms commonly found so the next go
discuss a little bit about sample
collection and DNA RNA shield is our
region that we really created for all
molecular testing for that matter for
DNA and RNA but really it has a major
advantages for microbio mix and the
reason is it preserves both the DNA and
RNA at ambient temperature it
inactivates all the organisms present
preventing growth any decay or also
prevents any pathogens from being active
after the fact so that the you way you
can ensure safe transport of your
samples no matter where you're
collecting them and an example of a use
of this was actually in the during the
MERS outbreak in the Oman desert the
army actually was ordering a lot of
shields from us at the time because they
were using it for collecting the nasal
swabs from the camels and two of the
major reasons why they needed it was
because of the hot desert temperatures
they need to stabilize nucleic acid the
course
also they need to inactivate the
pathogen for transportation so Jeanne I
shield takes an unbiased mugler snapshot
at the time of collection meaning this
it really freezes a sample at the time
of collection this allows you to get
that picture immediately as soon as you
collect it there's no changes and I'll
show a little data about how fast the
sample in fact can change in the case of
a seagull sample if you're not
collecting in a media that immediately
stabilizes nucleic acid in activates all
the organisms works and blood urine
works with stool soil swab essentially
any sample you can imagine it's it's
functional with so kind of reiterate it
preserves nucleic acids in ambient
temperature and activates the pathogens
all the organisms in fact and
streamlines purification and i want to
emphasize streamlined purification
because of the article that i pointed
out earlier where they noted that
high-throughput methods were commonly
identified need for microbio mix well if
you're perfect if your if your reagent
requires any reagent removal then it's
very difficult to streamline the
purification do the fact that you have
to introduce either Senna fication or
something else to remove reagents in
addition to that anytime you're causing
space separations it introduces by its
and this number of articles written on
this already so DNA our shields highly
automated there's no region removal you
can go directly into your purification
method so some data that supports the
DNA RNA shields ability to stabilize
nucleic acids at ambient temperature so
we have some saliva data here rt-qpcr
qpcr for both fly us through one tissue
those tissues actually solid tissue
chunks here indicating the ability of
shields actually penetrate a solid or
semi-solid sample and then on the bottom
right you'll see some data exemplifying
house shield not only the stabilize the
MV rt-qpcr but we can actually look at
it visually on a gel at 37 degrees c
within three days you already have a
significant degradation of
the RNA is indicated by the
disappearance of the ribosome abeyance
and smearing so how this applies also
specifically to microbiome X is if you
collect a on the top here you have a
stool sample collected in DNA RNA shield
we look at it for a month you see the
profiles doesn't change at all community
profile remains the same however in the
case of a stool sample collected not and
shield just left alone you see even
within one day the proteobacteria and a
1000 bacteria already start changing
their relative composition quite quickly
causing pretty significant bias and
these results towards organisms that
would normally be found and much much
lower abundances and again pathogen
activation or organism actin activation
as a whole but we've tested various bugs
influenza bola HSV some BSL two gram
gram positive gram negative organisms
sugar toxin-producing coli listeria
monocytogenes cryptococcus neoformans in
the case of yeast we've tested and you
notice the DNA RNA shield enables
complete and activation of these
organisms for safe transport and
actually in the lab and also safer for
the lab techs or researchers actually
working with the samples so discuss a
little bit about purification now so
design a really spent significant effort
in validating our purification line of
products for microbiome news because
previously microbiome X wasn't the major
use of say a fecal or a soil kit people
were doing many other things but
microbiome looks as the holes grown so
much the needs have actually changed and
so's imma really sought to meet these
needs by developing a kit aimed at the
microbiome community specifically so we
aimed at a non-biased lysis and fish and
purification and low bioburden so that
for low for low sample input so we have
very low contamination so that the
reagents are all clean and in addition
to that also efficient inhibit removal
so that two of the most common sample
types which are fecal and soil samples
are rich in inhibitors an inhibited PCR
etc which are in port
for those methods so a little background
if you look at chemical lysis on the
right here compared to our theoretical
this is actually using our standard you
notice the chemical Isis is inefficient
at lysine the gram-positive organisms
you have a huge over representation of
the gram-negative organisms while the
demo by Omix DNA many kits that we are
releasing we'll use as mechanical Isis
however mechanical Isis is not all
created equal that was actually a lot of
our validations was creating the correct
system that buffers the beads etc to
provide an unbiased efficient lysis of
all the organisms we actually found that
even not all be beating devices are
created equal and we actually recommend
that use the standards to even titrate
your BB device how long on what speed
you should be using a BB device to
optimize your yields but more
importantly to ensure you have an
unbiased representation of what the
sample actually is high speed units will
require less time of course and lower
speed units require much more time so
then we also looked at three of the most
common methods used in the literature
basically the three most cited methods
for fecal and soil samples and the one
on the right is supplier Q that's
actually a chemical licensed method even
though it's quite commonly used in this
field we were surprised by it but that's
what the the literature stating and do
the fact that it's a chemical lysis
method you actually see bias again
towards these gram-negative organisms as
you'd expect supplier m is actually
using mechanical lysis and this is
demote cited method and for the
microbiome in civic alee and you notice
it also is a bias towards the
gram-negative organisms inefficiently
lysine many of the gram positives and
then the HMP protocol which is the human
microbiome project protocol is actually
using the supplier m kit here but also
adds a heat heating step of and what we
found or what we suspect is is that the
heating step actually further license we
need is gram negatives but isn't in fact
actually further enhancing the lysis of
many of the grand positives again what
we'd like to reiterate is that many
these things weren't actually developed
these original kits weren't developed
for the specific use of microbiome Ock's
that's why ex-wives I'm ou had to
develop a standard in order to validate
the methods to ensure that we had a
method that was unbiased and it was
really looking to provide a cert that
caters this community specifically as
the needs have emerged then we decided
to look at the same profile using the
four same methods of looking at actual
fecal sample and you notice the damage
by Omix DNA minikit which was unbiased
using our standard in the previous slide
we actually have high yields but also a
much higher abundance of Firmicutes so
the first of all discussed the yield a
little bit this yield is directly
indicative of the fact that the life's
efficient is greatly enhanced and again
this was a key point because it's about
efficient lysis of all the organisms or
vast majority your you risk a bias of
your sample and then in the case of the
fecal sample you notice that this data
closely aligns or agrees with the data
we observe the standards at the
firmicutes the gram positives being
life's more efficiently with the saml by
Omix DNA minikit and the other
gram-positive bacteria and you notice
that the bacteria DS actually represent
a very small fraction of the sample
however the other methods show bacteria
t's actually composing a much larger
fraction and misrepresenting what is
actually present in addition to that
we've upgraded our license system as a
whole to ensure that the DNA is actually
a higher integrity of course the bead
beating the mechanical homogenous a shin
is actually still going to cause some
shearing but through some optimization
we improve the average size of the DNA
coming out of the sample with majority
bit of peering 10 KB and above making
this potentially amenable to some of the
third gen sequencing methods then
looking at all so our PCR inhibitor
removal ability so common PCR inhibitors
are potent Alcestis humic acids phobic
tannins you know all these things are
very common in people and soil samples
and this is one of the Richer inhibitor
samples that we've dealt with and that's
why we use this here as a one of our
controls that actually to optimize our
whole system and what this is is we're
looking at bay p a standardized input of
everything using a plasmid so all the
cycle numbers should actually be
identical and then we increase the
amount of lu eight president and as le
weight increases you would either expect
the mini inhibitors president you'd
expect to see the inhibition increase or
no amplification which is now by Omix
kit you see that the sample remains at
17.5 cycles approximately and supplier
M&P they're still good about ten percent
of the lu eight however as you increase
the amount of lu eight you notice that
the samples become completely inhibited
lastly we also then we worked on
developing a polymerase that was low
bioburden this particular polymerase has
less than 200 grams of DNA which is less
than a single bacteria coli genomic
equivalent which makes it ideal for many
of the many of the microbiome expand
that concludes my section and then i'll
pass it off to Chichen now you can Ryan
for that informative presentation I will
now turn it over to dr. tongue for its
presentation morning everyone oh so this
is sweet and tampons mo research I will
continue the presentation of the right
so my part of presentation will focus on
Deimos effort in without much effort in
standardizing library preparation and
analysis in micro farming analysis so
generally there are two ways to profile
a mixed microbial community one is based
on targeted sequencing an attractive
region can include 16s rrna genes from
the IES regions and eukaryote 18s rrna
genes the other approach is based on our
shotgun sequencing both ways have
advantages and disadvantages the the
targeted approach is robust and of
locals
also have limited coverage and limited
resolution for example the chicken s are
using targeted sequencing cannot detect
a new carriers and virus and in most
cases it can only identify bacteria to
the genetic level on the other hand
Shogun metagenomic sequencing sequence
all available DNA and because of La in
Syria you can identify all organisms
except RNA virus and you can trace my
clothes to a strain level however it
also has some disadvantages for example
it suffered it has problems of
incomplete database and host DNA
contamination it also have a relatively
high cost as I'm will research with
other both as sequencing services all
walk thoughts and pipelines have been
optimized and validated using as a
mobile is i'ma biomech microbial
community standard in the following our
chip I will introduce some examples of
our optimization efforts for this work
folks so normally our sickness are our
new gene targeted sequencing or sickness
profiling is the first choice for many
researchers looking for our profiling
and Biggs microbial community the
library preparation process of thickness
profiling is basically a PCR duplication
process as you know in a PCR reaction be
among or PCR product many depends on two
things the among of initial templates
and the number of pcr cycles the Imam of
initials in place in a unknown sample
can vary from a few copies to millions
of copies for convenience and in order
to have enough pto product from a
variety of samples many researchers
choose to have a fixed and relatively
high number of pcr cycles for all
different are for all different samples
especially in a form of 96-well plate
for example in a human microbiome
project postcode essays like 30 cycle
and in the earth microbiome project they
recommend the use of like 35 cycles
running the PCR reaction for 35 cycles
can allow you to have enough PCR
products for sequencing even from a
highly diluted sample but these were
over run the PCR reaction for those
samples that are not as diluted and over
running the PCR reaction can cause the
formation of PCR camry sequences the
figure on this slide shows how pcr are
chimeric sequences can grow if a PCR
reaction went away the PCR reaction
shown in this figure have about 10
milligram of genomic DNA input from
Massimo biome expander and because of
the use of standard we can identify all
pcr karmaloop sequences using the using
you time and the reference our new gene
sequences we were present in a Salem and
as you can see in this figure running
the PCR reaction for just 30 cycles can
cause the pcr chimeric sequences to take
up more than thirty five percent of the
final or PCR product many researchers
choose to rely on bioinformatics tools
such as you time to filter out these
chimeric sequences however is highly
questionable how effective that approach
can work for all unknown samples as I
will research we don't use a fixed PCF
we don't use a fixed number of PC
articles for all different samples we
adjust the pcrs cycles for each
individual sample we develop a process
allow you to adjust to control each pcr
reaction in a 96-well format and they
are for controlling pcr camera formation
from results rolling and dealing with
the problem afterwards in 16s sequencing
normally the more your sequence the more
texture you will be able to identify
however many of those hexes miley device
from our artifacts in sickness
sequencing the potential source of
I've seen 16s sequencing can improve pcr
camera reagent and causes our protest
contamination sample cross-contamination
parco contamination my sig run over run
carry over pcr errors and sequencing
errors etc the defined composition and
the extremities are low impurity level
of the demo by Omix standard allow us to
assess the effects in sickness
sequencing salary the figure this
speaker this pie chart shows the
microbial composition of the dermo
barmak standard when sequence and
analyze it using a regular workflow in
which no measures were impressed to
control these aspects and as a result as
many as 40 to eat bacteria general
identified while the standard should
only have a bacterial genera this page
on the right hand side I shows the
microbial composition of rows I'm Obama
Costello win sequence and analyze it
using our current workflow and in this
case our measures were in place to
control low bioburden to limit PTR can
be no information to have a very good my
sweet one and four and also to have
other para somatic controls and as a
result we only identify a bacterial
genera which agrees perfectly with the
composition of that standard so one or
all calibrator is a big call facility
which routinely process a large among
samples for tequila sequencing and they
participated in a beta test of hours I'm
obanak standard and the profile the
initial profile deforms in our standard
look like just the pie chart on the left
hand side and obviously they have some
optimization work to do for their own
workflow now let's talk about our show
commander metagenomic sequencing the
library preparation process of show
comedy genomic sequencing it's a much
more complicated process it contains at
least five steps DNA fragmentation and
repair a tailing adapter ligation and
TCR purification the library preparation
kit allah
preparation can call an x over X T was
provided by Lumira for shoka metagenomic
sequencing and this kit is very popular
because it is shorten the whole process
from five steps to two steps which is
tekkaman tation and pcr communication
however now convenience might come with
surprise that many researchers do not
know the sequencing of coverage buyers
can occur because of GC content
variation we read that there might be
some problem with the next day XP kids
when we compared side by side with our
internal matter for chokin library
preparation in a when using the demo by
Omix tender for Shore consequently the
microbial composition shown on this
figure was determined by mapping the raw
is against weapons database they will
contain inner inner centers and while
the results from our internal library
preparation method a quiz almost
perfectly with the theoretical value the
results from the next hour actually kids
had some disagreement and the biggest
still friend comes from the organism of
staphylococcus aureus and this algorithm
happened to be the organism that has
lowest GC content in our standard which
only has about thirty 2.7% my mapping
the raw sequence in Greece against the
weapons genome one can visualize GC
content variation and sequencing
coverage side by side and this figure
focused on norwegian a 10 kb region from
the genome of staphylococcus aureus the
panel natok shows to the GC content
variation and the bottom two panel shows
the sequencing coverage variation now
the panel in a meadow shows the case of
NextEra x EK and as you can see and as
you can see the sequencing coverage
increases when you seek on
increases and decreases when GC content
decreases so on and so forth and the
basically share a very similar twin but
you don't see this phenomena in the case
of the whole internal matter as we
mentioned earlier such GT buyers can
cause a bias in the exclamation of a
micro be abundant and in a case of
staphylococcus aureus for some regions
they have extremely low deeds accountant
the researchers might not be able to
recover any sequence for from those
region and this is definitely
problematic in some applications our
mobile McMichael your standard contains
multiple organisms that spend a white GC
content range from as low as fifteen
percent to as high as eighty five
percent and this allow us to assess GC
bias in a complete way so the figures in
this slide compels the two of library
preparation process we can in DC bias
over three genomes were contained in a
microbial standards these three genomes
will pick through it which is the
content low medium and hard the pictures
on these figures represent the GC
distribution in each genome and the
curves we please represent the
normalized sequencing coverage
distribution along to the content
ideally if the sequencing coverage has
no bios caused by GC content the
normalized GC content should always
equal to one and we can see this is
almost the case in the in this is almost
a case in the case of using the our
internal matters however in however in
the case of the mixer electrical would
seem under representation for regions of
bones no GC content and hygiene she come
here so with
within our mubarak sequencing services
we also provide a day of art and
comprehensive arithmetic and statistic
analysis this slide gives some examples
of typical operands here's a summary of
our second as our new gene targeting
sequence in services because of the use
of the assam obama extender we can until
the data of size quality and as you
control 22 min to maintain no velvet and
allow us to deal with samples that oh
they have extremely low power biomass
and all services a total solution the
customer just in use send out the
samples and we can take out the risk
with all these square features we also
provided with a good price for our
services we recommend our customer to
connect samples in DNA on a shield for
unbiased sample prefer for unbiased my
copy of preservation and president
inactivation we use some about by Omix
DNA mini kit for unbiased DNA extraction
and we use some obama global burden DNA
polymerase for low-power burden control
and we need meat pcr cycles to control a
PCR camera formation the DNA extraction
and library preparation will perform in
outer cream room to prevent processed
contamination and most importantly all
our workforce and pipelines have been
optimized and validated using the demo
biomech microbial standard this is
summary of our shotgun metagenomic
sequencing services so basically we use
an internal method for unbiased library
preparation we use high C for
high-throughput sequencing and
sophisticated a bioinformatic tools for
data analysis so in the end I would like
to finish my presentation with a real
story from boo boo so boo boo is AB cut
that belongs to my colleague mark so one
day boo boo was a diagnosed to have the
so-called top at optic atopic dermatitis
on one of the
porch basically it's a skin disease
assumed to be caused by allergic
reaction and boo boo was given like NT
information drugs for treatment my
colleague mark was suspicious about a
diagnosis and decided to conduct a
simple of my co bombing study so he
connect samples using swab from the
disease port and save the samples in DNA
and RNA she boo-boos recovered slowly
for about one month and after recovery
mark collect the sample from the same
every year and and then send us alerts
send low samples to us for Michael
Bionic sequencing we sequence the sample
we suppose sickness RNA gene targeted
sequencing and fungal ideas targeted
sequencing while there's while the
fungal community has no has no obvious
difference between the disease sample
and a control sample they also draw a
dramatic difference between them in a
case in a bacterial community so
basically the bacterial community in the
disease sample were dominated by two
bacterial genera stop the cookers and
stepfather cookers remember many members
for these two bacterial genera are
common passengers and they also commonly
find in a case of like co-infection so
many members so members from this to
bacterial genera of gram-positive
organisms they are very capitalized and
i doubt if and i will question like if
if one can get such a if one can get one
can see such a dramatic difference
between these these samples if not using
like if not preserving the sample is
Indian arrows here and and process them
using the diamond bar means my cup o my
copious
or sammobile nicotiana minikit so
hopefully in this presentation will
convince you that the importance of
using the reference material in micro
bombing studies and using as a mobile
mix microbial standards and research
have created a completed complete and
unbiased solution for micro biomech
composition palma profile so we have the
analogy of for example connection we
have DNA are we have a mobile mixed in a
mini for DNA extraction we have demo
biomech low bar button DNA polymerase
for library preparation we have a
thermobaric microbial standard as a
quality control for what whole workflow
and we also offer the mobile make
sequencing services at total solution
for my programming studies so in the end
I would like to thank all my colleagues
at Zama research who have contributed to
the work presented in this presentation
especially to our to dr. Larry jar with
our deep director and dr. M the foreman
who designed DNA on issue next we would
take questions thank you both for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box down by
clicking on the green too and a button
at the lower left of the presentation
window Ryan Kemp and dr. sweets and tong
will answer as many questions as time
permits and first question is how do we
address microbiome X biases and tissues
with low abundances of microbes
oh so we can you can you need to go to
question again absolutely how do we
address microbiome its biases in tissues
with low abundances of microbes so in
the case of low abundant is very
critical 20 min 10 and 222 it's very
critical to have low bow low output and
control for all your process you need to
our control though you need to have
procedure to maintain global burden in
your reagent and also during the process
as I mentioned in our thermo Tomic
sequencing services or our relations
were manufacturing by ourselves which we
have which we have full control and all
the process we for DNA extraction and
likely preparation we have to do it in
South African room to prevent posit
contamination its microbial standard a
mix of the bacteria and fungi which can
then undergo DNA extraction correct so
we have new Spector's oh let's say we
have two standards one is the their
mirrors of each other but one is the
extracted DNA and the other one is the
microbes pool bacteria keep intact
membranes and DNA RNA shield we are
using PMA to remove extracellular DNA
that's a tricky question they do
maintain a intact cell wall especially
in the case of many of the tougher gram
positives and yeast but they it is
demian a shield is lytic so that's why
it's safe for transport etc but it's
still uneffective for the evaluation of
biases associated extraction because the
cell walls remain intact of the tougher
organisms especially how do chimeric
sequences form during 16
library preparation for this question so
they are there are several publications
in vetting investigating PTR camera
formation in 16s library preparation so
a PTR camera is a problem in PCR
reactions in which there are a variety
of different but also highly similar
templates coexisting one potential
mechanism of how they form is that in a
set of PCR elongation early elongation
termination results in partially
amplified sequences in one cycle and
this partially amplified sequences where
you are used in subsequent cycles as
primers for further elongation when they
are needing to a different temporary a
highway product from two different
templates is produced again this
communal sequences are totally
artificial and dramatically increase the
alpha diversity of the sample just like
what we seen in a case of our moon with
profile using our using our standards
and they will bring more more they were
bring a lot of noise to to the data
which might very important discoveries
they need to be removed and taken cal
our saima by Omix standards optimized
for high five percent and low fat zero
to one percent food samples so to
emphasis reiterate i think this refers
to the extra the extraction technology
and yes we have appendices and methods
for dealing with essentially any any
sample type and then we can work with
you on that how did GC content variation
cause bias and sequencing coverage in
shotgun sequencing um so country there
is no perfect exploration of expert
explanation to how a DC bias occurred
some reports have shown that it can come
from the process of PCR
application some indicate some indicates
that it might come from the sequencing
platform itself but according to our
results because we don't see obvious GC
buyers in our internal agua preparation
process we think that GC buyers caused
by the sequencing platform should be
subtle if existing the next day waxy kid
has only has two cells enzymatic tag
mentation and pcr amplification and the
bias we observe can come from either of
those I still get enrolled in the beta
testers einmal by Omix microbial
standards or when will the products be
released yes you can still still get
involved in the beta test and the
product will release if the beginning of
July but free samples for the beta tests
are available now and you can sign up
you can you notice that we have designed
by Omix web page listing available on
the on the slide right now you can go
there for more information it's it
possible to purchase the microbial and
DNA standards for local validation and
development work we can send you stuff
now a free of charge for your for your
validation and testing can you tell
about a brief principle of RNA DNA
shield it's a lytic reagent so that's
the general principle behind why
inactivates things however in terms of
stability that's kind of our our secret
sauce but it stabilizes both DNA and RNA
at ambient temperature for greater than
a month this DNA RNA shield protect both
DNA and RNA of bacteria and fungi and
single solution correct
and let's just see if we have more
questions coming in or if being real be
pending you left a moment here okay
looks like
c'mon it
how can you assess whether these methods
are in quotes unbiased the gold standard
has been highly debated unbiased is use
a little loosely here it's only unbiased
relative to our standard but our
standard is including many organisms of
differential hardiness etc it's the
closest that we can get to unbiased
without including say another hundred
organisms or a thousand organisms so
that's our philosophy on it is that
we're we're moving towards as close to
an bias as we possibly can but you're
absolutely correct there's no guarantees
absolutely unbiased in all contexts one
hundred percent at a time but everything
that long-term centered up sorry and
everything is based upon the standard so
that that's our criteria have you done
long-term studies of the protective
effect of the RNA DNA RNA shield can I
get clarification if F is with respect
to the stability of the DNA and RNA and
if that's the case then yes we have
long-term studies actually DNA is stable
out for years RNA is we guarantee at
least one month but actually is stable
even longer and then of course we say
ambient temperature at 30 days but
there's some variability there depending
on if your ambient temperature stays 37
versus your enemy temperatures sitting
at 15 all the time I would like to once
again thank Ryan Kemp and dr. quantum
for their presentations do how many
final comments want to thank everybody
for attending today and we hope to see
you guys that maybe ASM and we're also
going to be at the NIST workshop in the
fall dr. time yeah so we are going to
add some night next week so hopefully we
can if you're interested in our topic we
can have more
discussion about more details about
process and there was a question about
whether or not the slides will be made
available and yes the slides will be
made that made available my
understanding is also the presentation
will be made available I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions we would
also like to thank our sponsors I'm oh
Research Corporation for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
sheet button at the bottom left corner
and follow the process to receive your
credit this webcast can be viewed on
demand through December 9th 2016 lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time bye